um michael did actually cut to the heart
of the problem
but i approached the same problem from
uh somewhat different perspective really
informed more by uh my experience with
the arms control negotiations and when
you sit at the table
things look quite different often
well i i don't see many students in the
audience but for those who are president
i can tell you that
are the books like of
getting to yes are don't actually
reflect
anything that goes on at the
negotiating table yes
it's a great book to teach but it's not
a good book to follow
as you negotiate treaties so i would say
that
yes we are at a really critical juncture
maybe we already actually passed the
juncture
honestly as i do not see much hope in
saving the existing
or network of arms control treaties
i don't see much hope of for extending
even
the new start treaty
i think we're entering the world of
unregulated arms race
uh maybe not so much in numbers
isn't on new capabilities all but these
new capabilities
make war more likely i'll
let me cut at this problem
at several levels uh the more technical
level so uh the arabs control actual
level
is that well if you look at the inf
treaty especially
i don't see much use for existing
procedures
and mechanisms are to resolve concerns
to me the situation uh
with the russian missile violating the
inf treaty or other
the u.s or
accusations of such violation well in
fact looks quite similar
we had similar uh cases before
while i was still so at the foreign
ministry
and let me tell you uh back yeah that's
like already many years ago
but back then similar issues were
resolved in a very different way
the way it was tackled by both sides on
nowadays simply did not allow for any
resolution whatsoever
so
oh you and that's really why the treaty
collapsed
i do not really uh uh try to claim that
i
know uh for sure whether
there was a violation or not and frankly
it actually doesn't matter
what really matters from my view from
a practitioner's point of view is the
fact that there was a chance to resolve
that
and the chance was not taken
second a big issue
now sort of the higher level uh the big
issue is
so what do we address in arms control
isn't that has been really fundamental
difference
uh that really came out to the fore
especially uh clearly during the obama
years how do we deal with nuclear
weapons
or do we deal with military capabilities
in the united states really tried very
hard
to reduce nuclear weapons yes that was
the prague speech and
so everything uh to which russia
actually said
uh but nuclear weapons
is just one part of military balance
why don't we tackle things like missile
defense and long-range conventional
weapons
oh that difference is to an extent
actually philosophical
but also quite practical during
world war ii the humankind lost about 50
million people
are using weapons that were really quite
primitive from today's point of view
so um if we
just eliminate nuclear weapons do we
save the human kind or do we
open gates for
a new conventional global war
we don't have an answer i'm not trying
to answer it i'm just saying that we
need to think about that
uh the trends are not very oh
it was optimistic yes and let me be
actually very
cynical here and even brutal
it's at the end of the cold war and for
the following
25 years the united states did possess
the monopoly
on advanced conventional weapons we
talked to our two wars in the gulf
we talked the balkans we talked libya
it was really wonderful world where it
was possible
to reduce reliance on nuclear weapons
because we got wonderful
non-nuclear so
our capabilities
well really let's go back to the 70s the
war in vietnam ended
yes it was a defeat he said the united
states would not really go to war for a
very long time
why because the traditional
conventional forces were unusable yes
the soviet union lived through the same
experience
so in afghanistan
i would say that after vietnam and
afghanistan the world
entered a qualitatively new
stage the stage of peaceful
foreign policy uh the stage one clause
of its was actually wrong
because war could no longer
be continuation so so
of policy by other means is
unfortunately that stage was very
short-lived
because now we got advanced conventional
weapons
quite precise on not much collateral
damage
we don't go to the battlefield
yes and uh things are really wonderful
uh what happened in 2015 it was the
first
use of similar weapons by russia
on battlefield in syria so the monopoly
was lost what do we see now
nuclear air launch cruise missiles
low yield warheads
oh it's up for trident
i'll look at things like that this
walkie gap like in europe and generally
big russian a military threat to nato
uh well i think it's important now to
understand
all the nuclear capabilities and
conventional capabilities
so
i'm sorry oh they're universally related
well in fact russia now uh says no we
now got conventional deterrence we don't
have to rely on nuclear weapons that's
really wonderful
yes well somehow nato does not
see that as wonderful so yes that's kind
of
uh the second level is the third level
that i think
needs to be addressed uh to understand
why we see
all the dismantlement of the arms
control framework
is the broader concept of international
law international regimes
and multilateralism the dominant
perception
in the west on not just the united
states
is that we're good guys because we are
for international law
and multilateral so
whose approaches uh russia is not
well that's actually not true
well in fact russia is a conservative
international law a multilateralist
country
yes it adheres to conservative old you
know kind of fundamentals
of international law so sovereign states
are are you're not bound by the
international regime unless you
expressly
so who's agreed to that
uh for treaty to enter
into force everyone should sign and
things like that
he's in uh is in the west after the end
of the cold war
it was more like the majority actually
rule so
the majority of states agree that
something is a good thing so yes
we perceive going
uh with that policy well just recall
90s we developed a concept of
humanitarian
intervention well it actually does
violate traditional
international law yes that's a gap
actually in the body of law
well since it's for a very good reason
well let's actually go ahead some states
might not support it he hasn't veto it
at the united uh on nation security
council but
we do it for so uh the common good
uh we go to war
over kosovo well that actually did
violate the unc
uh so the u.n charter but it was for
very good reasons
yes and then we the independence of
consula
and in 2009 the united states did file
a fascinating legal
uh justification for that
well it was called the u.s legal opinion
on the independence of consular a
surprise surprise in 2014
um um
moscow took that document and so to the
last word
implemented it in crimea yes
but we don't accept that because
uh that for because
that was for a bad reason
so uh we are into
this conflict between our two
conceptions
of oh so international law
but as we have this fundamental conflict
and we don't really talk about it much
at least in the west uh we do see
and we are concerned
about what we see on the surface isn't
the surface is
so
odd or the dismantlement
of the arms control regimes oh can we
overcome that i think chances are low
yes the chances are low because we talk
about
uh uh things are
all that are like on the surface like
the threat of war in general
or nuclear war specifically uh
and we do not even try
to seek some kind of a common position
on the bigger questions
what's international law
what is strategic stability uh
what we should account for as we write
our new treatise
yes as long as we do not address these
things
well
always i agree with you is i'll go to
church and put
a candle yes and hope that well we all
survive
uh and i can tell you that down the road
survival will be
much more difficult
to be honest the cold war
standoff with nuclear weapons was
nice stable or understandable
i would feel quite comfortable right now
to be honest but we are entering the era
of
our new weapons of the hypersonic
weapons
when leaders will have two or three
minutes
or uh to or to make a decision
in this world no
well seriously uh back during the cold
war
you see
the opponent's missiles flying yes and
you got 20 to 40 minutes
to think uh to verify the warning
to connect or to the opponent
so then they ask
oh what the hell is going on
well now you got oh two three minutes
so also you have to react on first
warning
and what's uh the likely mode of
reaction
yes it's actually the buttons right
we lived through a similar period a
quite short period though
in like 83. uh
when american short-range
intermediate-range missiles in europe
could reach moscow
in seven minutes
uh that challenge was resolved in
87 by the nf treaty
are given the state of relationship
between the west and russia i do not see
such a treaty
or something similar in the foreseeable
future
so let's enjoy life and pray thank you
[Music]